c'est l'anniversaire de notre ami jean
jacques bourdin aujourd'hui social base
est allé la retrouver très jolie en plus
impopulaire mois voilà ah le voilà
comment il va et chaussures bonsoir
cyril bonsoir à tous alors ça va bah on
tâtonne ou un abat jour d'hui vous savez
c'est l'anniversaire de jean jacques
bourdin il fait ses 71 ans et vu qu'on
est dedans c'est que du qui fait qu'on a
fait kiffer stéphane plaza la semaine
dernière et bien aujourd'hui on va faire
kiffer et jean jacques bourdin et comme
vous le savez je suis pas venu les mains
vides je suis venu avait alors t'es où
théo la monsoise a changé c'est pas les
brésiliennes ces les pom pom girls
devant le siège de bfm tv
vas-y vas-y c'est vas-y devant on va
aller on va aller les voir avant la
mi-temps alors faire plaisir il est
brillante et une serre que je vous ai
amené mazet brabo via les tahitiens
merci à je connais les mecs sympas yalla
yalla forts de l'année les revenus des
petits soucis avec eux vous savez que
georgia qu'il a eu des petits soucis
avec son permis il la audi tout ça ouais
bah je vous ai ramené la une nouvelle
voiture il s'appelle ping au regard des
îles et là bingo
ah oui comme à ben oui il a fait du bon
hockey
[Musique]
ça allez on y va
attention une partie loin conjugaux
également fait attention à pas perdre
les points électrique allez vas-y vas-y
maintenant on est là on est là au délà
on est là on est là vas-y regarder on va
essayer de dire bourgeois a déjà regardé
les frères tu peux pas rentrer bonjour
non alors ils ont ils ont dû fermer en
voyant tout ça ils sont 10 ou la lame et
fm vois pas ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
alors il ya bfmtv aussi donc c'est passé
de l'autre côté on va vous l'avez
compris on essaye de l'autre côté
basile basou s'acharne nous ouvrira les
yeux pas nous ouvrirons passionnés oui
mais ils voient que c'est toi le mec il
voit que c'est toi ça ça sacha ils sont
en pls à laterrière oui super cecos ont
tendance à ça j'ai rentré je ne pouvais
pas match aller reste là-bas pour la
saur qui fait georges a comme ça fait
une fête et autres bonnes valeurs at à
la voiture et là tout à l'heure je
trouve ça il ya excès trouve ça fou que
les journées lesparre en bois aussi
c'est qu'on vient faire un truc sympa on
fait la pub de tf1
c'est vraiment un cadeau chasse est
d'ailleurs un ferment les portes c'est
parce que je pense que je connais que
marc olivier fogiel je pense que si
marco et tout court je pense qu'il va
leur ouvrir mais franchement on sait pas
est ce que vous voulez que j'essaie
d'appeler marc olivier fogiel
enfin la pub la sent que c'est le patron
de bell et de bell seront enfin non pas
de grands directeurs et ben on va
appeler marc olivier fogiel dans un
instant pour essayer au moins de faire
entrer
sacha elle va à l'achat avec voilà au
moins sacha elbaz voilà on va essayer de
le faire entrer regarder en russie les
tombes mocassins
petite beauté on se retrouve dans un
instant il ya un instant ça chahute base
était devant et bfm tv
et apparemment ils veulent pas le
laisser rentrer et qui connaît bien marc
olivier fogiel le patron vous et moi bah
ouais vous et moi ne répond pas non
c'est vrai quand je l'appelle
j'arriverai pompe à la journée vous
voulez que j'en attends quand gens
importants
j'essaye alors marc olivier fogiel qui
est un pote jolie et mathieu peut
confirmer
ouais on s'aime beaucoup voilà et bien
sûr alors cette hausse ont cessé
d'écouter en plus chez les concurrents
mais on peut être concurrents et amis
je vais l'appeler tout de suite et je
vais essayer de voir s'il peut faire
entrer jure que c'est vrai ya pas très
longtemps je les appelais je l'appelle
il décroche mis à l'eau jeudi c'est
mathieu bitume en mer hachée avec macron
époux verts accrochés aux arbres et
c'est ça les amis de son deuxième
sonnerie sera pas qu'on l'appelle marqué
comme à mon avis de croire que je suis
avec vous ils me répondent pas nouveau
patron de bfm on va voir s'il va me
rappeler pendant l'émission à ibrahim
envoyer un message à un ami cyril je
suis en réunion
jusqu'à l'émission en direct a pas cette
heure alors je lui mets marco on est en
direct
bah oui c'est qu'ils parlent de toi
troisième laisse rentrait tous ensemble
on anime tous les missions lettres entre
et la personne de petite taille dans une
voiture et qui est devant la porte et il
y a un gars à moi je dirais un gâteau à
bord d'un devant bfm
les gens ne nous appartiennent pas lire
si une à l'accueil
amiens gâteau à jean-jacques bande à
l'accueil
hague à tous
[Rires]
the black bomb ariel il est avec un joli
mais vraiment ça il est avec un homme un
garçon est petite taille dans une audi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
des danseuses et des données si je
t'embrasse et chantant je t'embrasse
voilà montré que je vais la regarder sur
des sachets vous entend déjà le dit moi
je voulais y avait un gars moi devant
bfm pour les jours l'accueil un gâteau 5
bourdin l'été avec un garçon de petite
taille dans une audi layton alors on va
voir
voilà je vais vous dire ça y est